all right hi everyone today we're
looking at state of the art reviewing a
radical proposal to improve scientific
publication so this has been on my mind
for a while the review process for
modern science especially machine
learning is just broken I've spoken
numerous times about the fact that we
need to replace it with a better system
and now Samuel Albany at I'll have
actually come up with such a system and
we're going to explore it today I am a
big fan of this work and I'm 100% on
board with this so they basically say
peer review forms the backbone of modern
scientific manuscript evaluation if you
don't know what peer review is in
machine learning right now if you have
some genius idea so here is your idea
that's a light bulb by the way you write
it up into an eight page PDF yes it must
be PDF and yes it must be eight pages
he's submitted to a conference which is
some kind of so you've made it to be
accepted in a conference proceeding and
if the conference organizers of course
are just a bunch of people they can't
review these 1000 million applications
that come by themselves so what they do
is they recruit experts which are called
peers so peers are other people these
are called peers and they have usually
written up their own papers and they can
critique each other's paper and they
decide what gets accepted and what
doesn't now I've spoken numerous times
of how this is super noisy right now
they're way way they're not enough peers
they're not experienced enough so
whether or not your particular idea gets
accepted is extremely dependent on on
probability on a coin flip usually and
it's just overloaded and just makes no
sense and they asked the same question
is this fit for purpose in 2020 and we
need to replace it and support so they
you can already see they they
of want to automate this away with their
state-of-the-art review score and the
score will be an out of 10 score that
can be integrated into something like
archive and you know display right away
so they have some requirements to this
new system what should it be done it
should have the ability to scale very
important our current review system
doesn't have this right their current
review system relies on other humans
reviewing your paper and that means that
the reviewers need to scale with the
amount of papers which just isn't the
case currently so a new review system
must have the ability to scale right and
them you know automating the reviews
away or scaling it up in a distributed
fashion does this speed yes because
right now if I submit my manuscript for
review it takes them months to review it
and our science progresses faster than
that so a speedy more speedy version of
peer-review is definitely required and
then consistency and this is the most
shocking part right there is a the
ground 2014 new rips experiment which
concluded that 57% of papers accepted by
one committee were rejected by another
committee and vice versa reviewing the
exact same paper different committees
came to completely different conclusions
to an astounding degree so basically
you're flipping a coin of whether or not
your paper gets accepted or not and I
think this is just not acceptable and so
they propose these three things speed
scale consistency and their new methods
certainly has this now let's jump down
here where they introduced this
state-of-the-art reviewing s/o a are so
they say okay the quality of a
scientific work can be judged along
three axes
efficacy significance and novelty so
there are these three pillars right
efficacy which means is is kind of how
effective is your work in achieving the
goal in machine learning that's usually
to train some good classifier or
something like this then the other one
sorry is significance right significance
is how how relevant is what you've done
to the to the field right and the third
one is novelty so you know in your your
scientific work should be an original
contribution to the knowledge of mankind
and therefore it should be novel right
so the more of these three things you
have of course the higher your score
should be and here in the middle is
where the highest scores should be so
imagine this is kind of a landscape and
so you want to grade papers along these
three axes now they have a pretty good
method of of assessing these in an
automated fashion so first of all
assessing efficacy so efficacy they say
is best assessed by determining if the
proposed method achieves a new state of
the art I think that's not really I
don't think you can really doubt this I
mean this this is this is kind of the
gold standard of whether your paper is
effective is whether or not it achieves
a state of the art I mean I it might be
a bit of a controversial opinion but if
a paper doesn't achieve a state of the
art it's you know why why do you even
care like no one cares so from they say
from an implementation perspective they
can they can use the hand kind of abused
a fact of the current research
environment is that you don't actually
have to
review this yourself but the author's
themselves can be relied upon to state
this repeatedly in the text right and
this this is important so the author's
will state that they have state of the
art many many times in the text if they
have actually achieved it if they
haven't achieved it or not so sure about
it they probably won't repeat it as many
times this is can be can kind of abuse
now to distribute it basically you know
imagine now these these all of these
reviewers they don't they don't have to
do this work anymore they can just
distribute to all the authors of their
own papers right because the authors in
the text by the way the text structures
is kind of an NLP approach to reviewing
kind of NLP mixed with game theory right
so the other authors themselves if they
have state of the art you you'll have to
do some stemming and stuff but they will
put that into the text a lot so it's a
bit controversial but the the authors
here proposed to simply count the number
of word occurrences of state of the art
in the case insensitive very important
in the text right it stands to reason
that a higher state of the art count is
preferable of course alright so the
second thing so this might be a bit
controversial the second thing
significance and they now make the claim
significance is measured by efficacy so
they simply the efficacy term so if your
paper is effective at achieving its goal
you can also say it's significant for
the community because again significance
like if you have state of the art then
your paper is significant if you do not
have state of the art then your paper is
obviously not significant because why
should it matter if you don't have state
of the art in a in a given task
it's useless all right so we weigh it
twice that's pretty good
and then novelty now here they take much
of the same approach they say the
authors probably state this so how much
do use the word novel in their
manuscript will dictate so here they say
okay the novel wow this is failing me
hello how much they use the word novel
in the text will probably be an
indication I don't think so though they
do do the smart thing of they include
they includes the works they include the
related work section from this sorry
they exclude the related work section
they say we make the key observation the
individuals best place to make the
judgment are the author's themselves
since they have likely read at least one
of the works site in the bibliography
I don't agree here I think a better
method would be to simply count the
number of references and a lot lower the
amount of references to relate at work
the higher the novelty right because if
you if you think right if if this these
are current papers right and you place
and your paper is here right you'll have
a lot of related work right so it's not
as novel if you were like way out here
you will have maybe one or two related
works so it's it's way more novel if you
have less references so this would be my
kind of criticism of this so there's
this novelty thing here I think this
term should be replaced by kind of a
graph centrality measure or something
the account of how many references you
have would be enough probably all right
so they define their score their score
as we saw is the SOTA term weighted
twice a geometric mean between that and
the novelty term which I've criticized
and they add the suffix out of 10
because out of 10 score is pretty
interpretable
so they divide by 10 here so so yeah say
they say that here we as attach a suffix
out of 10 because that's easy to
interpret and as you saw in the indy
kind of archive implementation right
here sorry this this will be then easy
to drink the grate right here so they
even give code right
they give code in the paper themselves
of how to implement this it's pretty
pretty easy and I think yeah even though
it's a quite a short paper it's it's
thorough and it's a good new method and
I think this could revolutionize
publishing and they even so as a bit of
a bonus they give the official
pronunciation of state of the art
reviewing which is something like state
of the art reviewing pretty smooth yeah
with that I hope you enjoyed this and if
the authors could just be a little more
subtle next time that would be great I
guess you'd have to go yeah it's nothing
more bye